en clair on va carrément la jouer télé
mais je veux bien vous connaît la télé
c'est en direct j'ai le trac mais aussi
pour le moment tu es en tournée oui là
je tourne je tourne oui je chantonnais
tuer ou à bages tincquois poitiers
aquatour 27 à limoges de 36 sahara
tu as dit le rire c'est jackpot
je fais du blé n'est pas moi qui disent
ah ah si c'est toi qui lis ça bon je
vais le défendre
j'étais première étonnée moi quand on
m'a dit ah oui en plus on est pays a
vraiment ce serait génial tant mieux
comme étant des choix 10 gbe garzelli
combien il y admire l'argent bigarrée
plus que moi alors qu'il est beaucoup
moins connu
c'est mieux que c'était moi tu as dit
j'espère que c'est toi qui la lie on dit
aussi le théâtre c'est le stade
supérieur des one man show
je parle pour moi que j'ai envie de
faire du théâtre pàp one man show parce
qu'ils manient commence je commence à me
sentir seul j'ai envie d'avoir un regard
en face de moi comme j'ai envie de ça
que je vais répondre ouais c'est bien et
font du risque on avait dit que tant
attaché de presse ne saurait après
vraiment la transition c'est que la
pièce de la pièce que j'ai écrites pour
jacques une meilleure ouais ça cette
transition je passe par l'auteur et puis
après j'ai envie de rêve de jouer avec
les copains sur c'est quoi c'est quoi
cette pièce ça s'appelle comment pièce
montée et c'est une pièce de théâtre
pour une femme seule pendant une heure
et demie donc tu écris un one man show
pour du fameux théâtre moi la preuve que
c'est pas des sketches tu l'a connue
comment jacques une meilleure que
j'aurais dit elle m'en parlait d'elle
quand j'avais repart également dit que
j'adorais qu'un jour elle a dû le savoir
être puis elle m'a appelée en gambie
monchi josem bien rencontrons nous c'est
une technique ça oui je sais pas comment
faire quelque chose qu'on peut dire aux
jeunes qui débutent oui moi le nom le
meilleur conseil qu'il faut redonner
c'est pas de faire ce métier quoi comme
ça si le fond malgré malgré ce conseil
c'est que ils en ont vraiment besoin
c'est un métier qu'on fait pas par envie
je crois jamais vu confier par besoin ça
suffit pas ou alors on s'appelle jean
pierre françois a beaucoup de chance
je ne peux être que j'adore s'appelle le
colonel oui tous les matins 6 heures il
ya ya ya un type il faut absolument
trouver qui c'est qui joue de la
trompette ou du saxophone je suis parce
que c'est comme instrument mais ça
réveille tout bon
en plus il joue pratiquement toujours la
même chose ces irritants comme sur
quelque chose tu as fait la remets toi
force un enchaînement tout ça de suite
qu'est que tu as fait l'armée dans la
ville du bol j'ai commencé j'ai fait de
la télé avant de faire de l'armée quand
je suis arrivé trois jours je leur ai
dit moi je suis capable de le faire mais
mais mais je si je m'arrête maintenant
pendant la non alors que ça commence à
marcher mal que deux j'avais pour
affaires on est d'accord et puis j'ai
donc je parte il m'a pris à part ils
m'ont dit on vous laisse partir libre
j'ai gagné et mais en échange si vous
êtes amené à cannes public vous tapez
pas trop sur l'armée un deal